2009 a été une année très chargée en
sciences eu plusieurs découvertes qui
ont repoussé vous savez les limites de
nos connaissances et ce dans plusieurs
domaines la santé jusqu'à l'univers qui
nous entoure on revient sur les
événements qui ont marqué l'année ont
prédit de l'année science et c'est
toujours un plaisir parce que vous savez
qu'avec renault manuguerra gagner qui
est là chaque semaine on comprend mieux
la science
on essaye fort merci beaucoup de nous
d'être avec nous faisait on va commencer
avec une image marqué tout le monde une
image un peu floue ce faux dit
la première image du trou noir et on va
la revoir ensemble
vous savez que ça semble à peu près du
bugue moi je préfère je préfère l'image
une bague en diamant il ya un côté plus
mince que l'autre être un peu flou mais
la distance à laquelle se trouve que là
on va leur pardonner succès majeur cette
innovation majeure d'excès d'imagerie
surtout mois d'avril on savait qu'on
avait déjà la découverte de l'année
entre nos mains le 7è ce point là c'est
vraiment cette première image un trou
noir c'est qu'on va voir à l'écran dans
pauvres dans pas longtemps
c'est quelque chose d'assez unique le
four applique les trous noirs c'est les
objets les plus puissants de l'univers
c'est des objets tellement massive que
même la lumière pour leur échapper
est ce qu'on va voir sur l'image que la
photo qu'on va voir à l'écran dans pas
longtemps
c'est la silhouette d'un trou noir qui
se trouve aussi ceux ci dessus c'est
exactement la vraie photo de trous noirs
ça c'est la vraie l'avancé des
animations ceci la vraie donc ça peut
être un bien qui s'apprêtent une bague
en diamant avec eurosat de sa garde à ne
pas de perspective est ce qu'on voit sur
l'image mois un trou noir qui fait
qu'une masse de 7 milliards de fois la
masse de notre soleil c'est gigantesque
ils se cachent au milieu de la galaxie
m87 social 53 millions d'années-lumière
de nous donc on va pardonner le côté un
peu floue de l'image est ce qu'on voit
le sait vraiment la silhouette sombre du
trou noir au milieu qui a entouré d'un
disque de matière brûlante qui tourne
autour du trou noir juste avant de
disparaître à l'intérieur pour toujours
estimant important c'est une image
d'avoir c'est techniquement cela et
c'est quelque chose de très difficile à
faire ça nécessitait le travail combiné
de 8 radiotélescope à différents
endroits à travers le monde sa a été
l'image a été prise en avril 2010 site
mais il a fallu et la quantité de
données était tellement énorme que fallu
deux ans d'analysé pour qu'on puisse
avoir l'image qu'on a aujourd'hui est
d'abord l'image prouve une fois pour
toute l'existence des trous noirs
scientifiquement c'est quelque chose qui
est important en faire
ensuite les chercheurs croient que
étudie les trous noirs est capable de
les voir ça va essayer de mieux les
comprendre
ça va nous permettre en même temps de
mieux comprendre toutes les toutous les
toutes les lois de l'univers enfin ils
sont encore très difficiles qui ont
encore certains certains éléments qu'on
maîtrise pas encore tout à fait et en
les regardant dans un environnement
extrême comme un trou noir ça nous
permettent de mieux comprendre et
peut-être de résoudre certaines de ces
questions de l'encore plus que ce soit
en parler vous savez des voyages
traverser un trou noir permettrait
d'atteindre de nouveau le long des
rendus dans la science fiction avec ça
mais peut-être qu'un jour quelques
milliers d'années
ça va être capable de faire ça on va
rester dans l'espace oui qui l'eût cru
la conquête de la lune est revenue à
l'avant place est revenue à la mode
cette année pourquoi c'est pour
plusieurs raisons la lune c'est un
endroit bas scientifiquement c'est
important d'y retourner
il ya eu les les roches qu'on trouve à
la surface de la lune ça contient se
sont figés lot puis 4.3 milliards
d'années depuis la formation de la terre
donc c'est quelque chose qui nous permet
de remonter loin dans le passé et des
raisons économiques de retourner sur la
ligne certains minéraux qu'on retrouve
en grande quantité là qu'on peut pour
trouver sur terre il ya des raisons de
fierté nationale la chine veut retourner
sur la lune parce que parce que les
états unis l'ont fait d'ailleurs 50 ans
et dont veulent prouver leur puissance
et il ya aussi des raisons par exemple
on peut s'en servir comme point d'arrêt
pour fabre et même d'une barge avait
attendu pour mars à une base aux frais
du carburant pour ensuite continuer sur
mer dont la lune est vraiment revenu à
l'avant-plan 2019 50 ans après le
premier anniversaire du bassin quand
après l'anniversaire du premier pas sur
la lune donc c'est un moment important
et il ya plusieurs pays qui ont essayé
de se poser sur la lune en 2019 pour
rappeler que jusqu'à maintenant et je
les etats-unis la russie et la chine qui
ont posé des sondes sur la lune et je
les états unis qui ont envoyé des
astrolabes bien sûr donc cette année ça
a commencé là on voit la chine ont déjà
essayé de poser une opposition sur la
lune sur la face cachée de la lune et de
la lune société un succès ensuite elle
est issue par israël et l'inde qui ont
tous les deux sièges chacun leur tour de
la ville de gaza pro fonctionne ont ils
se sont écrasés sur la lune les dents
les deux coffres aurait elle même si la
lune est à côté de nous se posent istres
un autre monde c'est quelque chose qui
reste assez difficile et l'autre élément
important en dehors des différents pays
qu'ils ont c'est d'aller sur la lune
celles entrant sein des compagnies
privées
donc on a vu le boeing et spacex qui ont
testé le
capsule pour envoyer des astronautes
dans l'espace c'était un demi-échec
spacek c'est un suisse au mois de mars
boeing ont réussi à l'envoyer mais n'ont
pas réussi les deux courses au niveau du
privé et les deux compagnies devaient
faire leur premier vol en 2020 et
l'objectif encore une fois c'est pour
eux d'envoyer des astronautes dans
l'espace et donc les on sait que les
états unis veulent veulent aussi
retourner sur la lune en 2024 la chine
veut le faire donc c'est vraiment 2009
c'est un avant-goût des prochaines
années je pense qu'on va voir pour
essayer de retourner sur la lune avec
différentes compagnies différents petit
pays et les grandes puissances ou
intéressants vont venir ce plancher des
vaches voulez-vous soit la santé fait a
dit mme anglade sur lui cette année donc
on a commencé à avoir des premiers
traitements qu'ils utilisaient des
modifications génétiques non ça c'est
l'année passée quand il ya eu des
modifications et qu'on a annoncé la
naissance de me d'embryons modifiées
génétiquement c'est inquiétant mais là
cette année on a vraiment essayé
d'utiliser ces outils là pour des
traitements médicaux pour la santé et on
a eu plusieurs primeurs vraiment
intéressante on a essayé par exemple de
modifier des globules blancs de certains
patients pour 200 patients atteints de
différents cancers pour faire que ces
globules blancs reconnaissent plus
facilement les cancers et les combattre
on a aussi essayé de traiter certaines
maladies génétiques comme par exemple
des patients qui avaient des maladies du
sang des globules rouges déformés qu'ici
on appelle cela ni l anémie falciforme
les chercheurs ont essayé de modifier
leurs cellules génétiquement pour qu'ils
puissent produire des globules rouges
anormaux dans les deux cas ces études là
ont été pour l'instant c'est que ça
semble fonctionner les sept les thèses
de sécurité sont bien allés et ses
premières études là on espère que ça va
être le début en fait de nouvelles
sortes de nouvelles formes de médecines
et tout ceci a commencé cette année ce
qui est ce qui est vraiment quelque
chose de pas ciel s'est nettement
merci beaucoup et ça fait plaisir à voir